there are over 200 films here at
Sundance where are people actually
watching them we decide to put them to
the test with some movies of our own are
you gonna see any films no you guys see
movies in Sundance now or not movies why
you haven't seen anything really we're
just trying I'm hardly yeah Dakota
Fanning's skinny jeans of the heart do
you think there's a shot that that could
be nominated for a grand jury fries yeah
I think so yeah sounds like a great
movie everyone's talking about losing
Geppetto do you think that something
like marionettes and the struggle that
they go through could actually make it
to a grand jury desk if it's a well-told
story I think you could get anywhere
losing Geppetto thumbs up thumbs up
finding Amelia thumbs down
he didn't like that or you haven't heard
good things just having her name's you
have you meant a drama you like drama do
you think that a movie like skinny jeans
of the heart has the power to win a
grand jury prize here at Sundance I have
no idea sorry I don't know what that
movies about at all can you do the hard
know what um well it's more of its like
a love knot triangle but like octagon
well I feel like these aren't real do
you think that something like dreams of
Lahore gives other people hope when that
can get distribution oh you know what he
wouldn't be in the film industry unless
you had him he's got a film coming out
called the martyrs of sexting okay yeah
had you heard any big buzz about that I
mean I heard about it like all the
reviews and stuff like that but I
haven't seen it yet so I can't tell ya
is the martyrs of sexting gonna win the
Grand Jury Prize it's pretty edgy it's
over Alfonso Cortez the second work so
yeah so have you guys heard a faint the
funk which is getting tons and tons of
buzz it's about DJs in the 70s who also
are narcoleptics faint the funk you know
I actually heard about that today on
Twitter and I was like from some of the
people that have came up here and seen
it what about barista blue is here to
bug arista blues have you heard anything
about goats milk islands yeah I've heard
it I saw a little bit of thing about
that do you think that boats milk island
could win a grand jury prize it's like
said on the island of Crete there's been
a flood of goat's milk and sort of how
they go about cleaning it up and what
about hearts cab with Dakota Fanning
there's been a lot of hype around
roadkill melody are you guys gonna check
that one out
sure I can get tickets yeah because you
know right it's the sort of the other
side of what happens after you leave the
road kill good luck maybe promote some
more yeah road to Melanie guy name is
vegan my name is what know if I Mavis
Beacon if I may be speaking there's a
climate change conference coming up what
do you think that the leaders should
talk about when it comes to helping the
ball or anything